>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Helena Zinkham: Welcome
to the Library of Congress
on a wonderful fall afternoon.
I'm Helena Zinkham, the Director
for Collections and Services.
I'm going to start today's
special program with a few remarks
about the library's
amazing research resources.
Then Stefan Hansen from the Swedish
Embassy will introduce our speaker,
author and journalist,
Anders Rydell.
He'll talk about his new title
"The Book Thieves: The Nazi Looting
of Europe's Libraries and the Race
to Return a Literary Inheritance".
We'll have time for
questions afterwards and then
at 4 Anders will be available
to sign copies of his book.
At that time you can also
see examples of books
from the Offenbach Archival Depot.
The Library of Congress
had staff in Europe
after World War II whose
work included helping
to return the stolen books.
The display opens with an album of
photographs showing 350 bookplates
that facilitated connecting
books to their former owners.
For publications that
lacked any indication
of ownership the Jewish Cultural
Reconstruction group organized the
distribution of the orphans.
The Library of Congress did
receive several thousand volumes
from the JCR and close to 1500 are
identified in our online catalogue
with the heading "Holocaust
Era Judaic Heritage Library",
in other words the library as a
participant in helping to identify
and make sure the books
remain visible.
These books are cared for by the
Hebraic Section of the African
and Middle Eastern Division which
has brought three special titles
to share with you along with a
brochure that describes them.
Why would the Library of
Congress take an active role
in preserving international
cultural heritage?
Well, our name does emphasize
that our primary duty is
to the United States Congress.
We answer questions for them.
We undertake special
research projects
but we are also the national
library of the United States,
America's library and that means
that our mission is global in scope,
to make resources available,
to sustain
and preserve a universal
collection of knowledge
and creativity for
future generations.
Just a few numbers, we're
the stewards for more
than 164 million items
in 470 languages ranging
from printed books, newspapers and
of course electronic databases,
but also manuscripts and
maps, movies and music,
unique photographs
and sound recordings.
The shelving, they tell me they've
measured it in miles, 840 miles.
We believe you could drive all the
way to Iowa or Wisconsin and return
and the books of the library would
be lined up along the highway.
While we are known as the
largest library in the world,
what really matters of course
is content and quality.
We're fortunate to
have many divisions
with subject matter experts
to provide research guidance
and insight into these
massive collections
and we serve people
throughout the world.
The Librarian of Congress
likes to say that we preserve
and provide access to a rich,
diverse and enduring source
of knowledge in order to inform
but also to inspire and engage you
in your intellectual
and creative endeavors.
So whether you are new to
the Library of Congress today
or an experienced researcher, I see
some familiar faces in the room,
we have a world-class staff,
ready to assist you
either online or in person.
Of particular interest
this afternoon
of course are the collections
from or about Europe which number
in the millions, covering
Slavic and Eastern studies,
Eastern European studies as well
as Western European countries.
We invite you to visit
us or to reach
out through the email service
called 'Ask a Librarian'.
Taru Spiegel is our
reference specialist
for the Scandinavian countries
and organized the talk today.
Grant Harris, Chief of the European
Division is also here today as well
as our colleagues from the
African and the Middle East.
I'd like to recognize
their collective support
for preparing this program.
Is everyone's cell phone turned off?
Just to double-check,
okay thank you.
And please also be aware that
this event is being recorded
for future webcast,
thank you, Stefan?
>> Stefan Hansen: Good afternoon
everyone and hey Anders.
And first and foremost thank
you Library of Congress
for hosting this wonderful start
of the afternoon, this event
and we are very proud to
partner with you in this event.
And my name is Stefan Hansen.
I'm the Cultural Officer of the
Embassy of Sweden and we are located
in the House of Sweden
in Georgetown,
and if you've never
been visiting us,
please do because we are
having a lot of exhibitions
and literature events just
like this one, and seminars.
And we are open for the public and
free all the weekends, all the year
and you can come and visit
us not only for exhibitions
and theater performances, we also
have a library room for children,
dedicated for the youngest
ones filled
with treasures of Swedish authors.
So please come and join us there.
The Swedish government is very proud
of our [inaudible] about libraries.
Every municipality in Sweden has
a library, all over the country.
And the libraries' roles are
crucial for a democratic society.
And I would like also to say that
Swedes are the people in the world
that are reading the most and
that is based on facts [laughter]
and citizens of today need
to be exposed to training
and critical analysis of texts,
pictures and video more than ever
in this day and age
of filter bubbles.
And our minister, the Cultural
Minister is also the Minister
of Democracy and the Swedish
government believes that culture,
media and literature allows
people to grows as citizens
and that strengthens our democracy.
But now back to this and back
to Anders, we are thrilled
that the Library of Congress
has invited a Swedish author
Anders Rydell.
Anders is an established journalist,
editor and author of non-fiction.
"Book Thieves" is actually
the second part out of three.
The first part dealt with
the looting of artworks
in the Second World War and the
third will talk about music.
Anders' work, the Nazi looting of
art and books has been translated
into 19 languages including German,
Italian, Russian and Chinese.
And the "Book Thieves" is his
first book translated into English.
And this has been a very
busy year for you Anders,
you both published your
first book in English here
and you also had your son?
>> Anders Rydell: Yes.
You can, he's part
of the exhibition.
>> Stefan Hansen: So,
congratulations on that.
And please help me to give a
warm welcome to Anders Rydell.
[ Applause ]
>> Anders Rydell: Yeah, I will
first say, thank you for inviting me
to this great library and
as Stefan told before,
this is actually the second
book in a three-part series.
The first book came out in 2013
and the last book I'm working
on right now, on the
looting of music instruments,
sheets of music and
music literature.
But, it was when I started working
on the book about the looting
of art I also discovered
the looting of books.
And it was a couple of things that
got me interested in this subject.
First of all, when you
looked into the organizations
that organized the looting, they
didn't go after the art first,
they went after the
books, especially in France
and it was quite particular.
And another thing was
the scale of it.
The looting of books,
the operation to loot,
sort and transport books was much,
much larger than the looting of art.
Art was, if you compare
it, a small operation.
But the last and maybe
most important issue was
that the organizations that
were responsible for the looting
of cultural items, they weren't
really interested in the art.
The art was sent to the big
collectors like [inaudible]
and Otto Fichler [phonetic]
of course.
But what they were
interested in was the books
and not just books
but also archives.
And this was interesting
because these organizations were
also the central intellectual
organizations in Germany.
It was to, first of all
Heinrich Himmler's SS
and Alfred Rosenberg's
organization, ERR.
The common picture we have of
the book, the Nazis' relations
to literature is this, the book
burnings on the 10th of May, 1933.
And it's a very strong picture and
I think this image of the Nazis,
it's still powerful today.
And it's so powerful
because we want to believe
that the Nazis didn't read
books, they destroyed books
but the truth isn't that.
And I think the truth is
more horrific actually.
The book burning in May 1933 wasn't
done immense destruction of books,
actually quite few
books was destroyed.
Already in 1933 the Nazis started
looting books all over Germany.
The book burning was more a
ritual, a symbolic display
where they burned books in
a kind of ritual that a lot
of Germans at that time understood.
This was something that
went deep in German history.
A hundred years earlier German
students had burned French
literature of the Napoleon Wars.
But the most important
reference was to Martin Luther
and his burning of the Papal Bull.
Because, in the Nazi
perspective the burning
of the Papal Bull wasn't an
act of religious freedom,
it was a nationalistic act.
It was the moment when the
German people freed themselves
from the Catholic Church, the
power of the Catholic Church.
In Berlin 42,000 people
came together on this night
and the speaker here was the new
Minister of Propaganda, Goebbels
and he said "Here, the
intellectual foundations
of the November Republic
sinks to the ground.
But from the debris, a new
spirit will raise triumphantly
like the Phoenix".
The interesting part
here is the new spirit.
What was this new kind of spirit?
The Nazis didn't distance themselves
from intellectuals, from poets,
from librarians, writers,
researchers,
actually they recruited
them and very actively
because they needed them to create
the image of a new human being.
A couple of years later a
new institute was opened
in Germany, a historical institute.
And one of the historians here
described the role of the historian
in the new Nazi Germany and this
description I think is valuable also
for other kinds of
academics, writers, poets.
He said "The purpose of research
is not to fight directly for power.
But they can forge their weapons,
it can provide us with the shields,
it can train the warriors and awaken
the fire within them, hardening them
against the trials that lie ahead.
The goal of this Institute is to
develop weapons for the struggle
of thought, one of the most
important challenges of all".
The Nazis always fought to
cancel wars, the first one was
on the battlefield, the battle
of soldiers, tanks, machine guns
but then they fought the other
kind of war, the intellectual war,
the war about ideology, the war
where the Nazis wanted to prove
that the Nazi ideology
was the only true fate.
And in this war, the
looting was essential.
During the research for this book
I used this map and this map came
from Alfred Rosenberg's
organization,
Einsatzstab Reichsleiter Rosenberg,
one of the most important looting
organizations during the Second
World War.
And I took this map and made
a travel for almost six months
and followed looters in their
footsteps, from the book burnings
in Berlin to the great Jewish
libraries in Amsterdam, to Paris,
to Rome, to Thessaloniki and
of course Eastern Europe.
And the purpose of this trip was to
see what happened to the libraries
that were looted, what
came back, what was lost,
but also to get knowledge about
what happened to the people,
the communities, the families
that in some cases had built these
libraries through generations.
To simplify it you can say that
the Nazis looted three kinds
of libraries.
The first one was libraries on
socialist and communist literature.
After the invasion
of the Soviet Union
in 1941 the Nazis came upon
enormous amounts of libraries,
archives especially from
the Communist Party.
But there were also targets
in Western Europe and one
of the most important institutions
was the institute in Amsterdam,
the Institute of Social History.
And this institute had been
created in the early 1930s,
as you can say a response to what
happened around Europe at that time.
This institute's goal was to save an
important part of Europe's history,
the worker's movements'
libraries and archives.
And just in a few years they
built fantastic collections
because in the 1930s it wasn't
just political refugees,
there were libraries and archives
on the road that had been smuggled
out from the Soviet Union,
Mussolini's Italy, Franco's Spain
and of course from Hitler's Germany.
And one of the most important
archives had been smuggled
out in the early 1930s
from the Nazi Germany
and this small paper
here is a part of that
and maybe you can read
in the bottom Karl Marx.
This is the, what you
can call the first draft
of the "Communist Manifesto".
They had the hallmarks of
Friedrich Engels' Archive
and this archive was kind of
a Holy Grail for the Nazis
because the Communists, the
Socialists, the Bolsheviks were one
of the Nazis' main enemies.
But wasn't just the
political enemies,
because there were strong social
influences in the Nazi Party.
Early on, there were parts of
the Nazi movement that wanted
to nationalize the large
companies for example.
You can say that the Communists and
especially the Bolsheviks weren't
so much a political enemy,
they were something more.
They were part of what you call
the Bolshevik Communist conspiracy.
The idea that Jews
created the Communists
and the Jews ruled
actually in [inaudible].
And these ideas were
put ahead especially
from Alfred Rosenberg's
point of view.
And the Nazis always tried to prove
these Jewish Bolshevik conspiracies.
And one of the most
important proofs was of course
that the Communists' ideology
was founded by a Jew, Karl Marx.
Another kind of libraries
that were looted was the
Freemasons' libraries.
The Freemasons were one
of the first organizations
that were attacked in
Germany in the 1930s.
And, why did the Nazis
attack the Freemasons?
For one instance they
were a secret society
but they were also an
international organization
and both didn't work very
well in a totalitarian state.
But the Nazis also
had a special interest
for the Freemasons' libraries
and especially the libraries
on the occult, libraries on
witches, black magic, alchemy.
And this interest was
especially large in the SS.
I will get back to later what they
wanted to do with this collection.
This is a picture from Klossiana,
one of the oldest Freemason
libraries in Europe
and this library was
looted during the war
and had a fantastic collection
on literature on alchemy.
But of course the most
affected were Jewish libraries.
The oldest and most important Jewish
libraries in Europe were looted.
One of them was in Rome,
the library that belonged
to the Jewish community in Rome and
this library had a fantastic history
because it belonged to a
community with a fantastic history.
The Jewish community of Rome was one
of the oldest Jewish
communities in Europe.
Some of the first Jews came here
as slaves during the Roman age.
And this library had, went
through, down through the ages
and it was saved from
the Inquisition
in the 15th and 16th centuries.
In 1943 this library was
put on a German train
and the train headed somewhere
into Central Europe and
then it disappeared.
This library has never been found.
The Italian government had
tried to find it for ten years
but practically it failed.
And the author, Robert Katz
had described what this library
included, the only copies
of books and manuscripts
from before Jesus'
birth, from the time
of the Roman emperors
and the early popes.
There were engravings
from medieval times,
books from the first
printing presses and documents
that had been passed from
hand to hand through history.
But the places that you could
say, that were most affected
by the looting were a
couple of places in Europe
that you can describe as places
of Jewish culture and learning.
And one of those places was Vilnius.
Vilnius was the center, the
heart of the Yiddish culture
in Eastern Europe and it
was known for its poets,
its rabbis, its libraries.
And one of the most important
institutions here was YIVO,
the Yiddish Institute.
And as the Institute of Social
History this institute had a mission
to save the Yiddish
culture and history.
And during a couple of decades
they collected/sent out hundreds
of historians, authors, researchers
that collected folk tales,
songs, and ancient manuscripts.
This institution of course was one
of the main targets
of the Nazi looters.
The problem the Nazis had,
especially in Eastern Europe was
that they got more material
than they had Nazi researchers
that could read Yiddish or Hebrew.
So they solved this in a
very, you could say Nazi way,
they let the victims do the work.
They created slave labor groups of
Jewish academics, writers, poets,
that themselves got to sort through
the collections for the Nazis.
The sad story is that these
places of Jewish culture
and learning also were the
places that were hardest-hit
by the Holocaust and the Nazis,
because the Nazis saw this place
as dangerous, as places where
the Jews could fight back.
The other great Euro-center
of culture
and learning was Thessaloniki.
And to Thessaloniki or Thessalonica
as it was called at the time,
isn't as famous today
as Vilnius and it's
because its history is almost gone.
Here the Nazis succeeded.
This was once one of the
biggest Jewish cities in Europe,
like a center for a very
special Jewish community and one
of the few European cities when
the Jewish population dominated.
And this city had been founded
by Jews that left Spain in 1492
after the Reconquista, when
they were forced to leave Spain.
And when they came here from Spain
they brought a unique culture
because these Sephardic
Jews had been part
of what you call the Arabic
Translation Movement during the
Middle Ages and when a lot
of the classics from Greek
and Roman literature were saved,
because they were translated
into Arabic.
And they were often, the Sephardic
Jews that did these translations,
so when they moved to
Thessaloniki in today's Greece,
they took with them their books,
and this city already during
the 16th century became known
for its libraries, its culture.
And when the Nazis came here almost
400 years later people still spoke
Ladino, the ancient
Spanish-Jewish language.
This was a society a
culture, a whole civilization
that perished during the Holocaust,
not only the people disappeared
but also their history
and their culture.
The libraries and archives of this
culture were looted and scattered.
Today when you walk around in
Thessaloniki you see few traces
from this civilization that existed
here for less than 100 years.
But there are some traces,
outside the city walls
where there today is the
Aristotle University,
was once one of Europe's
largest Jewish cemeteries,
a half a million graves.
During the war this cemetery
was blown up, destroyed
and then they used the
stones as building material.
The SS used it to build a
swimming pool at the SS villa.
But also, ordinary Greeks used it.
So today when you know
what, where to look,
you can find pieces of this history.
I found it at a small wall in
the center that smelled of urine,
in a wall built in the 60s
and here I found a part
of a Jewish gravestone.
And you can say that these
words on this stone are there,
some of the few words that still
exist from this lost civilization.
Who were the men who were
responsible for this?
Of course one of them
was Heinrich Himmler.
The SS was one of the
big looters of books
and during the war they started to
build a big collection in Berlin,
a big library that they called the
Library of the Enemies of the Reich.
And it was a library with different
departments for Jews, Communists,
Freemasons, and Catholics, everyone
that they perceived as an enemy.
And at this library they
planned to study their enemy,
but not only to destroy them
in the physical sense but also
to fight their ideas,
their thoughts.
Here they're going to fight
the idea, the intellectual war.
But the SS also did
another kind of research
and especially research
on the occult.
There were some authors
on popular descriptions
of the Nazi interest in the occult.
It was an interest that went
through the whole Nazi movement
but it was strong especially in SS.
And maybe the most,
the strangest research
that they did was the witch project.
It went on for almost ten years.
And in this project they collected
material on thousands of witches
that had been burned from
the Middle Ages and forward.
And they collected this to archive
that was called Himmler's
Hexenkarrochek.
Why did they do this?
You could say that the Nazi,
that Nazi Germany was probably
the only regime in history
that was positive to witches.
They loved witches and they often
described them like Nordic amazons.
The Nazi interest in witches
is that, especially the SS,
they saw the witch hunts and
the burnings of witches as part
of a larger war between
civilizations.
The witches were victims in a war
between the Catholic, Semitic Church
and the true Nordic faith and myths.
It was a way for the Catholic Church
to destroy the true Nordic religions
and ideas in the SS perspective.
The other person that was
responsible for the looting
and maybe the most serious
collector is the man
in the hat here, Alfred Rosenberg.
He's one of the lesser-known
persons in the Nazi elite
but I think some of
the most important.
In the early 1930s Hitler
appointed him the role
as the Party's spiritual
leader, the chief ideologist.
And Rosenberg's mission
was to purify, develop
and protect the Nazi ideology.
And Rosenberg realized one thing,
that the Nazi movement
wasn't held together
by its ideology but
by something else.
It was held together by the cult
surrounding the man in the middle,
the cult, the Hitler
cult and the Fuhrer cult.
Rosenberg believed that if the
man in the center disappeared,
everything would come crashing down.
But, how would you build an
empire that would last 1000 years
if you have only, if it all
depends on just one man?
Rosenberg meant that they
needed something else,
of course they needed an
idea but an idea can't exist
without institutions
and he especially looked
at the Catholic Church.
He meant that what
would Christianity be
without the Catholic Church,
the power of this institution?
Would the Christian faith even exist
today without this institution?
Rosenberg meant to create
such new Nazi institutions
and he believed the two most
important areas were education
and science.
Already during the 1930s the
Nazis started to experiment
on special elite schools.
They created the Adolf Hitler
Schools for young, gifted boys.
Then they went to the
Ordensburgen Schools.
It was like a military academy
where a boy should read Goethe
and shoot the machine gun.
You should be what the Nazis
would describe as poetic warriors.
And they would finish
their education
at Rosenberg's crown jewel, the
University of the Nazi Party.
This was a school that was
planned to be built in the south
of Germany after the war.
And here the Nazis would create the
future leadership of Nazi Germany
and secure it, the future.
But these institutions
would also be the head
of the other pillar,
research and science.
Connected with university
Alfred Rosenberg planned several
institutions, spread out over
Germany that would study some
of the Nazis' favorite questions,
Indo-German, German history,
folk history, Celts,
Eastern research for example.
And it was for, mainly for
this kind, these institutions,
the institutes that the Nazis, that
the Rosenberg organization looted.
But there was only one of these that
was officially open during the war,
the last one, the Institute
of the Jewish Question.
And this was an institute
and a question
that Rosenberg meant couldn't
be, had to be dealt right now.
And it was actually opened in
1941 when the Holocaust started
and its projects and its operation
was connected to the Holocaust.
At this institute Nazi researchers
studied Jewish history, language,
culture and to this institute some
of the most important Jewish
collections were sent.
Why was it so important to study
Jewish history and culture?
When Alfred Rosenberg
inaugurated the institute he said
that it may come a day
when our grandchildren grow
up in a world freed from Jews
where maybe they can't really
understand the threat the Jews
proposed for our time,
therefore the goal
of this institute is to remind them.
And he said the human
memory is very short.
What Alfred Rosenberg was
afraid of was of course,
that future generations in a world
without Jews, would judge them
for their actions and that they
wouldn't understand why they had
to do this horrible thing.
I think one of the most important
lessons about the looting is
that it wasn't done to eradicate the
history or culture of their enemies
but to take control over it.
Because, if you own your enemies'
libraries, if you own their books,
their archives, you also have
the power to write their history,
that was the main goal
with the looting.
As Alon Confino puts it in his
book "A World Without Jews",
"Remembering the Jews
after a victorious war would
have been important precisely
because total liquidation of the
Jews could not have been achieved
by physical annihilation alone,
it required as well the overcoming
of Jewish history,
memory and history.
The Nazis struggle against
the Jews was never principally
about the political and
the economical influence.
It was about their identity waged
by the means of Nazi appropriation
of Jewish history,
memory and books".
The Nazis wanted a future
with generations to remember,
remember what happened
but only by taking control
of Jewish history and culture.
Could the Nazis also take control
over the memory of the Jews
in a world where they
didn't exist anymore?
In the Nazi world view the Jew would
become the devil and incarnation
of evil that would scare the
children long after they were dead.
After the war these books, libraries
and archives were found all
over Europe and their fate
was very different depending
on who found them and
where they were found.
Early in 1945 Stalin in a secret
operation created so-called Soviet
Trophy Brigades.
And the goal of these brigades
was to take as much as they could
from Germany but also
from Central Europe.
And the Soviet Trophy Brigades
took over 11 million books
to the Soviet Union that
were looted and many,
many more from German
libraries and universities.
Many of these collections were
scattered, separated and most
of these books have
never been returned.
It was a different procedure in the
West where the monuments men sorted
and succeeded in returning millions
of books at the Offenbach Depot,
a sorting center outside
of Frankfurt, among them,
many of the books that had been
found at the Frankfurt Institute,
but there was still a problem.
Even if you could find out
who owned a book there wasn't,
it was far from certain
that there was still someone
to return the book to.
As one of the monuments
men later wrote
"In the sorting room I would
come upon a box of books
which the sorters had brought
together like scattered sheep
into one fold - books from a
library which once had been
in some distant town in
Poland or an extinct Yeshiva.
There was something sad and
mournful about these volumes
as they were whispering a tale of
yearning and hope since obliterated.
I would find myself straightening
out these books and arranging them
in the boxes with a
personal sense of tenderness
as if they had belonged
to someone dear to me,
someone recently deceased".
Many of these books were later
sent out to Jewish communities,
to institutions around the world.
But still despite both the
efforts to loot books after war
and return them, there were
millions and millions of books left
in German libraries and in
other European libraries.
And, when I travelled around
Europe I found them everywhere.
In my book I especially
focused on a library in Berlin,
the Zentral und Landesbibliothek.
Today there are estimates
that there could be
around a quarter million looted
books just in this library.
And most of the looted books at
this library aren't valuable books,
aren't important books, it's
just books that belonged
to ordinary people because the
Nazis didn't just loot books
from important libraries and
archives, they looted from everyone.
In 1942 Alfred Rosenberg
initiated the so-called M-Aktion,
Mobel Aktion.
It was an operation where 70,000
homes in France, The Netherlands
and Belgium were emptied
of everything, furniture,
toys [inaudible] and
of course books.
And, hundreds and hundreds
of thousands
of these books were
brought to Germany
and often sold to German libraries.
And the library in Berlin,
they don't have big collections
either they have one or a few books
from thousands and
thousands of small libraries.
And today a small team of
librarians sort through a collection
of 7 million books by hand and they
have worked for almost a decade.
And they have returned 600
books, so you understand
that this is something that's
going to go on for decades
or maybe for generations.
One question I asked when
I came to this library was,
why hasn't this been
brought up earlier?
The libraries started doing
this research ten years ago.
And one important reason was
that it wasn't librarians
that were held responsible
for the crimes after the war.
The same librarians ought to be,
that had taken part of the looting,
held that position after the war and
often tried to hide this history.
They hid the traces and today you
can find a lot of books that look
like this, when you have tried
to destroy Jewish bookplates.
In other cases you have, they
have tried to falsify catalogues.
During the war there wasn't
a problem to put the 'J'
in the books for Jewish books.
It didn't look as good after the war
so they tried to make it a donation
from someone with 'J', Jiako
[phonetic] or something.
And, you can also ask, why is it
important to return these books?
They aren't valuable and ten
years' of work for 600 books,
and it's 600 books to around,
a little more than 100 people.
And in my book I wanted to do,
follow one of these single books
because I understood that every one
of these books also
carried a history.
And, as one of the librarians
here said it's often a history
that ends at Auschwitz.
And I came in contact with this
book, and this book was a book
that belonged to just an
ordinary German Jewish man
that was called Richjart [phonetic]
Kobrak and he was a lawyer in Berlin
and lived there with his
wife and three children.
And he didn't really
have a Jewish identity.
The family was Christian and he
had been awarded the Iron Cross
of the [inaudible] in
the First World War.
So, when Hitler came to power
he refused to leave Germany.
He meant that he was more German
than that Austrian Hitler.
And that was a mistake of course.
After the Kristallnacht
they understood
that they'd found a big mistake.
And they tried to get out
and they succeeded sending
out the three children
but Richjart Kobrak
and his wife died in Auschwitz.
I took this book and followed
it to Richjart Kobrak's son,
Helmet [phonetic] Kobrak.
Helmet Kobrak was 15 years old when
he came to Great Britain in 1939.
The problem was that the British
didn't see him as a Jewish refugee
so they arrested him and
deported him on a ship
with prisoners to Australia.
It took almost 10 years for him to
get back to his sisters in England.
I took this book and returned it to
Helmet's daughter, a woman living
in a small village
outside Birmingham.
And this book was the first
thing the family ever got back
from Richjart Kobrak.
This was a man that had
left almost nothing.
They didn't have any photographs.
They didn't have a grave of course
and in some ways this book was the
only proof that he ever existed.
I think this tells something
important about restitution
because with the focus on art,
restitution has been a lot
about the value of
artworks and money.
But I mean the moral
center, the moral quest
of the restitution isn't economical
compensation, that's important
but it's not the moral center.
It's to get back.
It's to give back something
of the lives
and worlds that were destroyed.
To return a book to Thessaloniki
is a way to return a small part
of a history that isn't
here anymore.
And this book here, it's practically
worthless, you can buy it
for a dollar at the bookseller
but for this family it's the
most important book in the world.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Taru Spiegel: Thank you very much
Anders for this very interesting
and moving presentation and
before we go to questions
and answers a word from our sponsor.
I'm Taru Spiegel.
I work in the European Division
and I have many wonderful colleagues
here and also from the African
and Middle Eastern and
elsewhere in the library.
We're here to answer your questions.
You can reach us by coming
here, by emailing us,
by going to 'Ask a Librarian'.
You just Google 'Ask a
Librarian' and there you are
and your question will be routed
to the appropriate people.
So, thank you, Helena?
>> Helena Zinkham: We have
a little time for questions.
Who would like to begin?
Yes [inaudible] or if
you want to come and ask
at the microphone, that's up to you.
>> I think.
I think [inaudible] First of all,
thank you very much
for your words today.
I, in your book I'm
reading with great interest.
In your book I recently began.
In your book I began reading the
chapter about Vilnius and one thing
that I was wondering is, throughout
your research, were you able to root
out or locate any books that
belonged to the [inaudible]?
>> Helena Zinkham: I want
to just briefly repeat.
So, for those who are watching
the webcast later this is an
appreciation for the
talk and then a question.
Has Anders seen any of the
books that were at Vilnius?
>> Anders Rydell: No, I'm
sorry I haven't actually
because they aren't there anymore
and as I think some people
here know, a lot of the books
from Vilnius especially
the books that were found
at the Frankfurt Institute,
were actually sent to New York.
>> New York?
>> Anders Rydell: Yeah, to
the YIVO Institute in New York
because YIVO had already at that
time a department in New York,
was like a side department
[inaudible] become the main,
the main YIVO because
[inaudible] was destroyed.
But it was a question at
that time that they wanted
to send the books back to
Lithuania but of course
at that time it wasn't
possible for YIVO to exist there
because as you know in the
Soviet Union it wasn't allowed
to have alternative
identities, not officially.
>> Helena Zinkham: So, it sounds
like head to New York City.
Other questions?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Anders Rydell: It was a library
of the Jewish community in Rome.
>> In Rome?
>> Anders Rydell: Yeah.
They had two libraries and I showed
a picture from the second one,
and it was the lesser
important library.
But the community's
libraries were, it's lost.
And, some believe it's in
Russia but nobody knows.
Some believe it had been destroyed.
And it's really sad because
it's such a fantastic library
and the library was
actually not that old.
It was brought together when they
took down the Jewish ghetto in Rome
and as you maybe know the Jewish
ghetto in Rome was the last ghetto
in Europe before the
Nazis created them again
at the end of the 19th century.
And these books were
brought together
because they had been hidden
because the Inquisition had went
into the Jewish ghetto
in Rome several times,
collected Jewish books
and burned them.
So, these books had been hidden
away from the Catholic Church
for hundreds and hundreds of years.
And then the Nazis destroyed them.
>> Helena Zinkham: There was another
question on this side of the room.
Please?
>> Have any families laid claims
for their libraries and [inaudible]?
>> Helena Zinkham: So the question
is, have any libraries made,
have any families made
claims for their libraries
as they become more aware
that the books still exist,
some of the books exist?
>> Anders Rydell: Yes, and
especially at this library
that I told you about, the Zentral
und Landesbibliotheck in Berlin.
They accurately search for people
but it's a very time-consuming work.
So, what they're doing
right now is putting
up all the information they can
get from a book, bookplates,
names and everything on
the internet so a lot
of people actually find them
when they're doing research
on the family, on their history.
But the problem is of course
that a lot of the survivors,
I mean were scattered all
over the world, changed name,
changed identity and
everything so it's.
And it's also difficult sometimes to
know who would [inaudible] entitled
to because one of the [inaudible]
went to Australia, one to Argentina
and one to the United
States for example.
So it's a very difficult question.
>> Helena Zinkham:
Anyone else, alright oh?
>> Were German scholars assigned
to revise or otherwise just,
more accurately distort
Jewish history
and if this was just
so, do you [inaudible]?
>> Anders Rydell: During which time?
>> During the Nazi, yeah
during the Nazi era.
>> Helena Zinkham: So I believe the
question is, during the Nazi era,
were any of the people
assigned to change history?
How has that come into
the literature?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Helena Zinkham: And how, okay
and how was this rewriting
of history challenged?
>> Anders Rydell: Yeah, it's
the, could I borrow your book?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
The Nazis, I mean they wanted to own
Jewish memory and history and some
of the Jewish writers, scholars
understood this especially
in Vilnius, and especially
one of the librarians.
The librarian of the ghetto of
Vilnius, Herman Kruk and all,
let me just find the section here.
Yeah, during all the time the
ghetto existed he put on a diary.
He wrote everything down, what kind
of books people borrowed,
what happened.
And they also created at the
library a secret organization
that collected all the German orders
and material from the [inaudible]
because they understood if the
Germans want to control our memory,
we must protect our history and
get it out somewhere, somehow.
Yeah, and after the, their ghetto
in Vilnius was destroyed Herman Kruk
was sent to a labor camp in Estonia.
Herman Kruk was deported to a forced
labor camp in Lagedi, Estonia.
He would continue to keep
a journal to the very end.
On September 17, 1944 he
wrote his final notes.
I'm burying the manuscripts in
Lagedi, in Herr Schulma's barrack,
opposite the guardhouse, six
people are present for the funeral.
He buried all of his diaries
to save them because he sensed
that something was wrong.
Kruk had a sense of
what awaited him.
The next day, he and 2000
other prisoners were forced
to carry wooden logs to a
forest outside the camp.
The logs were put down in long rows
where upon the prisoners were forced
to lie down on top of them.
They had built their
own funeral pyres.
After the Nazi guards had shot
the prisoners in the head,
another layer of logs and
prisoners were added on top,
and thereafter, another,
and another.
When the Red Army reached
the scene a few days later,
unburned bodies still
lay in the pyres.
But one of the witnesses of Herman
Kruk's funeral managed to flee
and went back to dig up his diaries.
>> Helena Zinkham: I think that
brings us to a good ending.
I invite you again to
view some of the books
from the Jewish Cultural
Restoration Commission that are here
at the Library of Congress as
well as the bookplate tools
that help match former owners
right at the end of World War II.
But there are also copies of the
books for sale in the next room
and Anders will be ready to sign.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.